Now we're going to take some time and build the RCP interface and we're going to be using that with the web app.
So let's go ahead and go to that screen.
Now you want to be able to build this first in the web because it's just easier than doing this on your iPad or whatever device you might be working with.
And I'm just doing this through the web browser because I've already launched which we did a few minutes ago as an initial test.
Now I have a tab called Sun Control. Now you can go to your tabs at any time and you can actually duplicate a tab, change the tab icon, or rename it.
So in this case let's duplicate this tab for a second.
And I'm going to duplicate this tab and I'm going to change the tab icon.
Say we want to have something for our rock or land and we'll just choose something random.
We'll just say Skull and Crossbones for ground. I found one that was actually pretty cool but now I can't find him.
He doesn't like me so we'll do that. Skull and Crossbones and apply.
Now it's going to be our land. We're going to rename that.
We'll call this rock. There's the rock and there's our sun control.
So you have a bit of that control here with the tab.
In our widgets here we can actually navigate and create anyone that we need.
Now in some cases it may not work. Like say I want to do a joystick to be able to control my cloud color.
That's not the most efficient way to do that. You want to do that with like a dial or you want to do that with a color picker.
Those are the best ways to be able to and color picker would be the most efficient in that case.
That's kind of how you want to tackle that.
Now at any time I can pull in any of these tools in here if I need to and then later on assign the objects to them.
But you can also pull your properties in ahead of time and then choose if you want dials, color picker, or slider.
But you'll see natively what generically they come in at first.
Let's go to our sun control and focus on that.
So in our sun control what we can do is we can first put in maybe a couple panels.
Like here's a panel here and I'll put another panel over here and we kind of stack them on top of each other.
If I want I could bring in a list. There's a list.
And I can choose these panels to be underneath a particular list if I wanted to.
Which is actually kind of nice.
But it's really up to you how you stack these.
So I can go ahead and kill these for a moment.
And you can hit delete at any time you don't want them.
And they can repopulate as is.
So I brought in a list in here and if I click on this list I can add new items.
I can say hey I got a new item we'll add another one and another one.
And we're all going to use these for the sun.
So the first one can be renamed and you'll do it here on the bottom left here.
Sun intensity.
The next one we'll choose is like I don't know sun color.
And then over here we'll choose sun rotation.
There we go.
And now with intensity selected I can go to my properties and choose my intensity.
And again I can rename these inside of my remote control preset.
That I've made in unreal.
But for now I'll leave them and I'm just going to pull that intensity in here.
With the intensity selected I can choose whether I want a dial or whether I want a slide bar.
I'll go to sun color.
Do the same thing.
Pull the sun color over and the picker is going to work pretty well.
Now you can populate these with sun color to have different aspects of your sun.
Like hey I want to put temperature in the same area.
And then you can just change the name.
You can customize these any way that you need.
And finally I'll go to rotation.
Grab my rotation.
And pull that right in here.
Now if for some reason it fights you.
Notice mine is fighting me on dials.
I can go in here and change this.
And it does fight you sometimes.
Maybe just have it temporarily as sliders.
Pull that in.
Get the sliders in there.
Once it's in there I can go ahead and select this.
And decide that I want to change this guy from sliders to dials.
And it will actually populate.
So if it does fight you.
Because that does happen to me sometimes.
Where I'm trying to pull it in.
It won't go in.
Because dials can be a little bit tricky.
You can always have it as its generic default.
I had changed mine earlier.
You can have it as a generic default.
Pull it in.
And then change it after the fact.
And it can isolate too if you want pitch only.
Pitch and yaw.
And you can see them disappear according to my selection.
Which is pretty cool.
And pretty convenient to be able to do that.
Now if I wanted to put more in here.
And I went back to my widget and say.
Hey I want to put another panel.
You got to be careful because this list is active.
It will actually push him in there.
So you might want to just take the time to go in here.
And just make another tab.
And we'll just say hey let's duplicate that last tab.
And this one will be really cool stuff.
I'm just being silly here.
Crazy talk.
Really cool stuff.
Rename.
And then we can change its icon again which you saw me do before.
So all this is available for you to get ready to populate and move and control things in your scene.
Now we're going to do this with the iPad.
You'll see me control later on on the LED volume.
But you can also temporarily see here if I switch from design to control.
We'll go to our sun control.
You'll see that I can now control my intensity here in my scene.
I can make it bright.
I can make it dark.
Go negative if I wanted to.
I can go in my sun color.
I can choose it.
And you'll see the web app is updating according to what I have.
Just remember you got to remember exactly where things are at in your scene.
So if you do undo.
You have to be careful because sometimes the undos aren't going to necessarily take.
That will set you back to default.
But you'll notice there's no really clean way to undo.
So make sure that you know where everything was parked before.
And there's my rotation control.
So I can do my yaw, my roll, my yaw, my pitch.
All these things are controlled at my fingertips.
And we're using Lumen so all this is going to update on the fly.
Which is actually kind of nice.
Ooh, look at that.
Made an evening scene.
And then we have yaw here too.
So we can control that also.
Really great to be able to do that.
But it's really easier to be able to do this ahead of time within the web app here.
But you'll notice in a minute here when we go to our iPad that it's actually already active.
And these settings are also talking to our iPad.
So we're not leaving any details out.
All those details are going to be ready to go and nested already.
So let's go to the slides for a minute for a quick review of everything we kind of talked about so far.
So again, review, we have control and design.
And you're able to choose which remote control preset you're working with.
We also have it here so that we can look at the ones that we have and we can choose where they want to.
Joystick, sliders, it can also go into your widgets and choose those ahead of time.
And just make sure that that control is connected, mapped to it correctly.
You'll notice that blue button, as you see in my slides, tells you that it's indicated that they are active and working.
Next, you also see that whatever is being controlled is directly correlated with what we have here.
So you'll see that one on my sample here.
It says with chair, location vector, and you'll see that that's connected here because it's active.
So just giving you another visual example of how that works.
Pretty straightforward stuff.
I really couldn't make this super, well, I guess I probably could make it complicated.
But it's not.
No matter what you do, no matter how you slice it, it's going to be pretty simple to work with.
And again, you can delete them at any time.
So if you're deciding, hey, I don't want that, you can delete it and you can redrag it into your scene.
Really great to be able to choose what you want, color picker, vector, slider.
And again, you can delete them and you can choose what the minimum and maximum.
I forgot to mention that too, but you'll see in my slides, you can choose the minimum and maximum for those items
when it comes to your adjustment on some of these interactive widgets.
You see a little gif here showing the same example I showed you where we had a list
and then we put the panels inside the list.
And that allows you to be able to organize things a bit better.
And again, you can put as many things as you want in there.
And it's up to you how you want to name them and organize things.
So there's additional resources for this.
Again, it's pretty straightforward.
You can duplicate, you can add a snapshot.
All these things are in here.
And we're going to be talking about snapshots later.
But for now, this is pretty straightforward when it comes to working with this particular system.
And again, you can choose your settings.
And if you're running into problems, if the RCP fails to have a launch icon,
was working previously and you can't go into the settings and click on and off,
you can force your web app to build at startup.
So if you do run into that, you can actually go into your settings and do that.
But that's not really the norm right now for 5.1, so you should be okay.
But if you do, we have a workaround for that.
In the next section, we're going to be talking about material parameter collections.
And I'll show you how to actually set that up via a blueprint.
And then towards the end of the class, this section,
we'll show you how we can interactively control those things on our volume.